california the home state of nearly one
out of eight americans is making an
abrupt u-turn
to try to roll back a surge in
coronavirus infections
more states are likely to follow
california has recorded nearly 110 000
new cases
in the last 14 days including another 8
000
yesterday governor gavin newsom has
ordered some businesses to close
statewide just a few weeks after letting
them reopen
and about 825 thousand students
in los angeles and san diego will not
return to school
as scheduled jonathan vigliotti reports
on the return
of restrictions covert 19
is not going away anytime soon just over
one month after reopening several
sectors of california's economy
governor gavin newsom is reversing
course yesterday he announced
gyms churches and hair salons would be
among those forced to close in 29
california counties while bars indoor
restaurants and movie theaters
will close across the entire state donna
bruner owns a hair salon in danville
she says she is heartbroken for her
employees and may
consider defying the governor's order
for them i
as a business owner cannot tell someone
you can't work to put food on the table
you can't work to take care of your kids
as health officials continue to sound
the alarm over the rising number of
cases
the state's two largest school districts
announced students
will not return to classrooms this fall
in a statement the los angeles and san
diego school districts wrote the
skyrocketing infection rates of the past
few weeks
make it clear the pandemic is not under
control
the health and safety of all in the
school community
is not something we can compromise other
states are also
grappling with how to get children back
in the classroom safely
some school board leaders in arizona are
calling on the governor to close
classrooms
and school buildings until october first
i cannot in good conscience put our
youth at risk
by restarting in-person instruction and
in new york governor andrew cuomo vowed
schools would only reopen
if positive tests in their region remain
below
5 percent over a 14-day average
we're not going to use our children as
guinea pigs
but as some school districts go online
others are fighting to stay open like in
orange county where last night the
school board recommended students go
back
into the classroom without face masks
and without
social distancing but new data shows
teachers are at highest risk
one in four teachers in the u.s have
pre-existing conditions that make them
especially vulnerable
to the coronavirus tony yeah it's not
just about the kids jonathan it's about
the instructors thank you very much